hi this is Nick Corning today we're
going to talk about react component
lifecycle react lets us define
components as classes or as functions a
component class can be defined by
extending react component the only
method that is required in a component
subclass is render as you can see in
this block of code components have
several lifecycle methods that you can
override to run your code at a
particular time in the process
these methods are categorized into four
groups mounting updating error
boundaries and unmounting in this
example we will build a counter
component and utilize all the lifecycle
methods let's get started with creating
a constructor your constructor takes
props as its object and we need to call
the base class or the parent class
method via super and pass in props
what this does is it sets this dot props
to props so it's available throughout
our class constructor is also the only
place where we can set state let's go
ahead and set a counter and let's use
that in the render method alright and
also want to have the console open here
and while we're looking at the console I
want to make sure I'm printing messages
in the various functions as well so we
can see the we can see the progression
so when an object's created when the
constructor is called
followed by render let's give this some
functionality to increment and decrement
encounters so I'm going to create a
couple of methods here increment which
whole set state on the counter and
incremented using the previous value and
add one to it
likewise decrement will decrement a
value
on that right here okay and let's create
a couple of buttons to allow us to
increment and decrement this we're going
to assign these methods to one of the
events for on click let's replicate that
for decrement oops there you go now when
we click this we're gonna see the
counter reflect the change and notice
that all that's doing right now is
calling the rendered method so let's
introduce a few lifecycle methods the
first one is component did mount this is
called right after render and when I
save this we'll see things we render and
what I want to do is also add markers at
the end of some of these render life
cycles so we're just gonna add a dashed
line so we know that this is a single
render call and if we were to do
increment there is another render a call
but does not call component in mount
because that is only triggered when the
component is constructed and essentially
gets added into the Dom however there's
another method called component did
update and this method actually takes a
few parameters there's a reference to
previous props the previous state and
snapshot let's trigger component did
update and will
a date log statement here all right
so notice that component that update is
not called here once we click increment
will see component it update I want to
add a line marker there as well so we
know that's another render so if I click
this you see the different sort of life
cycles that are triggered all right so
let's go ahead and add the ability to
mount and unmount this counter we need
to do that in nab GS so we're going to
create a constructor here with props
that are passed to the parent and then
set state in the constructor to with an
attribute called mount which will set to
true and a couple of methods to mount
and unmount the counter
we'll set state here just said mount to
true and likewise this will be unmount
encounter where mount will be false
let's go ahead and create a couple of
button elements mount counter and
methods on click to do this tub mount
counter and replicate that for unmount
counter
okay so another thing I want to do is
set disable to true or false depending
on the value of mount
alright so notice that the buttons just
grayed out now if I click on mount and
mount you'll see that some life cycle
methods were triggered all right but one
of the things we forgot here is to take
advantage of that state variable so I'm
going to use that in conditionally
render counter and if it's non set
amount we'll remove it from the Dom
alright so there you go so now this
should actually remove the counter let's
add another life cycle method encounter
this time it's called component will
unmount as the name suggests this method
is called when the components being
taken out of the dawn and I've set
another marker there there you go so now
a component in mount if I click on mount
counter you'll see component below
unmount was triggered and there you go
on mount the constructors triggered
because the counters component the
counter component is recreated these are
the most commonly used life cycle
methods but shift focus into some of the
infrequently used methods we have
another method called should component
update which takes next props in the
next state as its parameter parameters
sorry generally this returns true by
default the purpose of this method is to
let react know if render should be
triggered or not normally react does a
very good job at figuring that out
but sometimes let's say your state or
props gets updated and you don't really
need render to be triggered because
you're not changing anything on the UI
and especially if your render method is
a bit expensive to compute then you can
definitely gain some performance here
but need to be careful here because you
could fall into a trap
where you end up losing performance if
this method is using correctly let's add
your prop in ab ts that we're going to
pass into counter which we would want to
ignore okay so let's call it ignore prop
and whatever the value here is let's say
it's zero initially I'm going to create
another method here to pass an ignore
prop by generating a value and assigning
it to state so ignore prop is just add
the random we don't care what the value
is what we want to do next is pass that
prop in to the counter so we'll pass an
ignore prop equals this dot state ignore
prop okay and so that should pass this
through but what we also need is a
button to trigger that change so let's
call this ignore prop and then on click
we will call this dart ignore problem
okay there you go
so now when I click ignore prop it's
going to call render and component it
update mainly because something changed
on the parent and that was passed down
to the component but in this case let's
say we don't care about ignore prop
because we're not doing anything with it
we're not rendering it to the UI so we
simply want to ignore it that's where
this method comes into the picture so we
create a condition here to check for
when is appropriate to tell react not to
call render we're going to store this in
the state and call it ignore prop if
there is an ignore props value
and if the one in our state is not equal
to that value we want to return false
basically anytime ignore prop comes in
and if the value doesn't match what's in
our state we want to return false so
it's it's still being called here that's
mainly because we should check this type
of props so we're looking at whatever is
in our current props and if next props
is different than we know ignored prop
has changed and in that case we don't
want it to render anything well us had
any console.log years we'll all right
then I click ignore probably should
component of data is called but
let's look at this so it's going to
render for some reason we're checking if
the value exists and if that value is
not equal to what's in our props if
that's the case we do not render perhaps
we are looking at something incorrect
here let's see
you know prop is being passed in there
oh this should be ignore prop that's the
issue all right Dave the next thing to
look into is a method called get derive
state from props this is a static method
and it's called before every other
method and this passes in props and
state and the purpose of this method is
to give you a chance to copy any values
from props that you may be interested in
transferring over to state and in our
case we could add a another method here
that allows us to pass any random seed
value so let's say we start out with our
seed being some arbitrary value here and
what we can do is add a seed generator
method we're just simply going to set
state to set the value and seed to an
integer so we're going to parse a hint
and doom at random times 100 to scale it
up and that creates a method for us and
we also want to pass in seed
here from this top state that seed and
also create another button here then
maps to see generator call it generate
seed alright and I think the error we
were getting earlier here is that we
don't have a return statement so
anything you return from here gets
assigned to this date so if you don't
want to change state you simply return
null all right so now when I click
generate seed let me lower this nothing
seems to happen
I mean we see some life cycle methods
getting triggered here but it's not
really taking advantage of the scene
being passed in so let's take care of
that in this method here so we want to
check if a seed exists on the props and
if the seed that's in our state is not
equal to that seed that's passed then if
that's the case it will return a seed
value that's props that's seen and it
set the counter to props that see as
well and let's just default it to 0 here
in this state notice that counter starts
at 40 because we have set the initial
seed value to 40 here so I can click
increment and decrement and this
continues to work but I could also click
generate seed and that should change the
value of counter here all right
but the point here was to demonstrate
this life cycle method that allows us to
copy props into State notice that since
this is a static method we don't have
access to the instance of the object
there's one more or a couple more
methods we need to talk about so the
next one is called get snapshot before
update and that sort of goes right for
render
and it takes in previous props in
previous state and then we return a
value out of this this method is to
allow us to capture some properties that
are not stored in the state before we
rerender that component so let's say you
had a list view or a text area where the
cursor was in a certain row and column
or if the list was called a certain
location then he would be able to
capture details about that and then
handle that later on so whatever is
returned here gets passed into component
at update as a third parameter called
snapshot and that's where we could tell
the Dom to sort of set the cursor and
the carrot in a certain place and things
like that so that that's that method and
finally there is a method called
component did catch which is part of the
arab boundaries group and this takes two
parameters called error and info and
essentially it gives us a chance to
gracefully handle
you know any errors that we run into all
right so let's go ahead and call it noir
prop and also when should component
update do not renders call we want to
add one of the line markers so we know
that's the end of the update and let's
call generate seed and then we cancel
increment and decrement unmount and
remount it and now let's generate a
component that's going to create a
deliberate error so let's call this
error component and we're just going to
return a div with it accessing some
non-existent value and this is gonna
cause it to crash so let's say we add it
into counter right now so I'm going to
place that error component here when I
save you'll see that there were errors
that were triggered here now if I did
not have component at catch when I save
I lose everything that's rendered in the
browser and so I could have a downstream
component that generates an error and
it's not handled properly and it causes
the entire app to go into sort of this
blank screen so that's where component
dead cash comes into the picture it
allows us to gracefully handle some of
these so what I'm gonna do is once we
know there is an error we're going to
set state and set the error and info
properties on it and let's handle those
here as well and render we're going to
check for an error being present in that
case we're going to turn a div that says
encounter and error let's try to print
this out as well error has some
additional attributes that we need to
print so what we can do is just print
that out here to see what error contains
and then we can revisit this there you
go
it is revenge ring but the error is
right here so let's go ahead and look
for I believe it's a message there you
go let's take this out and all right so
we were able to handle our error
gracefully without everything else
crashing and that's sort of the purpose
of this method here let's let's trigger
this conditionally so what I'm gonna do
is add an attribute to state called show
error component and we'll set it to
false to begin with and we're gonna pass
that here show error component equals
this dot state show error component and
everything so loads but internally here
I want to make sure that we're looking
at props to see if show error component
is true in that case we can generate
this there's just actually made up
entirely just so that we don't run into
this and we can get the counter again as
we toggle this so we'll have to add
another method here let's call this
toggle error and we're going to set the
value there for show error component and
we're going to set it to negate it to
whatever it's set to and that should
actually
be called me a button here so let's add
that in toggle over and we'll just call
this toggle error and so I think yeah
there you go now as we click this it's
not reversing let's take a look at that
I see what's happening so this this part
works okay I think the issue is which
state error because we are not clearing
that once we set it here the component
ends up rendering the error over and
over again so all we have to do is look
at the props dot show error component is
true and if we have an error in that
case they go now we should be able to
toggle this let me do a quick recap we
have the constructor which is called
when a component is created followed by
get derived state from props which
allows us to copy props into state this
is not used frequently but there are
cases and such as this one here where we
want to pass in a seed for the counter
and have that be controlled internally
through the state that's when this
method is useful we have component dead
mount which is also an interesting place
to do things like Network requests or
handle like the initial loading of the
component for instance if we had a value
that said initializing the true by
default and based off of this value if
we were setting a specific if we were
showing a specific message we could sort
of simulate let's say we were simply
returning and initializing right so in
this case we're going to see that method
there I think I found the div it's gonna
show them the next line there and
essentially you know let's say this is
when the component loads initially it's
in the initializing state we need to
fetch some data and that kind of stuff
would happen right here let's just
simulate the start
set timeout and call a method there in
about let's say 500 milliseconds so
you'll see it flash briefly and we're
going to set the state on initializing
to false sorry I meant to do just said
timeout there initially I was thinking
about said state so there you go if I
were to refresh this notice you see the
initializing followed by the counter
showing up so that's sort of the purpose
of this method where you could make a
network request and when you have your
data again you can change the state on
your component and tell it to you know
maybe perhaps show a spinner while it's
loading content anyway while we were
doing the recap so after component did
mount should component update gets
called this is where we could hint to
react
do not call render all over again I
believe in the future that's how the
methods gonna work it's simply going to
be a hint and react will decide if it
wants to actually honor that or not and
this get snapshot before update which
allows us to store things like positions
of your list views or you know text
areas or whatever Dom components that
you can then pass on to component data
update and reassign those after the
render render of course takes care of
rendering content component get update
gets triggered right after render now
this is also similar to component at
mount if you wanted to make specific
Network requests based on certain
attributes or props or state values you
could do the same here you can actually
call set state in component dead mount
and it triggers a rerender but it
doesn't actually call the render method
twice it only doesn't want because of
the location where it's called under and
finally this component will unmount that
gets triggered when the components
removed from the Dom and component at
catch which helps us
sort of gracefully handle errors and
downstream components lifecycle methods
or render method and that brings us to
the end of this video hope it was useful
and if you'd like to stay up to date
with future videos consider subscribing
below thank you